okay fine but only because it's
Valentine's Day
and we love you right from the director
the Cornetto trilogy and an unspecified
amount of ant-man
comes the best videogame themed movie
since the wizard I love the power glove
it's so good
Scott Pilgrim vs. the world get ready
for the movie you couldn't wait to see
but didn't show up to support in this
cult classic full of so many awesome
fight sequences
and hilarious visual comedy you'll
barely notice that every character in it
is a horrible garbage person if your
life had a face I would punch it yeah
wait what I mean seriously these are all
bad people
except for knives I like knives meet the
collection of late 2000s hipster cliches
known as Scott Pilgrim he's an
unemployed musician who lives across the
street from his parents shops at
Goodwill it's sexually ambiguous
and complains about everything this is
gonna suck literally everything it
really sucks though what everything when
he meets a loose collection of quirks
and hair dyed known as Ramona Flowers I
changed my hair every weekend have to
get used to it
Scott will win her like a human sex
trophy by killing people cheating on his
girlfriend and being such an all-around
d-bag I cheated on you I cheated on both
his opposite is a really nice guy like
in there oh let's do next week yeah he's
this really nice guy indulge in two
hours of pure nerd wish-fulfillment
where a guy with no personality the face
of a toddler and the body of a
stretched-out toddler hooks up with tons
of girls that time it's Lisa that was a
misunderstanding the time of Holly that
wasn't what it looked like at Emmy
dumped Kim
okay then camera good news Kicks Captain
America's ass makes a lesbian orgasm to
dad and plays DDR with underage asian
schoolgirls who are obsessed with him
man no wonder the internet loves this
movie experience the definition of style
over substance
but when Edgar Wright is doing the
styling who cares stare in awe as he
mixes 8-bit animation with live-action
crafts frame perfect recreations of the
comic book and Heights Easter eggs that
correspond to the number of every
ex-boyfriend resulting in a movie that
truly feels like a video game that
you're watching someone else play so
strap in for one proto Millennials epic
journey towards maturity that ends with
him finally growing up and choosing the
girl he should have been with all along
wait a minute they didn't use that
ending they reshot it Zoey ends up with
Ramona why what was the point of it all
in be jealous and violin and chase after
a toxic relationship even when true love
is staring you right in the face
uh I don't get young people starring
ready player one madding pixel dream
girl kung foo fighters Tony Hawk pro
skater vegan Vegeta uh get a room
hipster kilgrave obligatory gay best
friend and hashtag mature Asian sidekick
Street winner to turbo
I mean it's fun but the comic book is
way better than the movie
no I'm that guy be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers boo nana fofanna
KaBlam ah the man in black ran across
the desert as the gunslinger followed
you're despicable
prepare to feel the wrath of a league of
evil exes I use an epic voice to mask my
insecurities reach out and touch someone